انا لا استطيع ان ارفع اصبعي عن الزناد
اني اقتل شخص ذاته اكثر من ثلاث مرات
الجنود الامريكيون يدخلون في حاله تشنج
عصبي اصوات بكاء الجنود تتصاعد وعداد
الضحايا في ارتفاع نعم يا ساده انها معركه
نفس الطويل وزاره الدفاع الامريكي ترسل
فوجا بعد فوجه ولكن لم يعد منهم احد ومن
عاد فقد جنونه وفقد عقله يا الهي عن اي
مجزره نتحدث الجنود الامريكان اصبحوا
مدفونين تحت الارض صنعته ليدعم هذه الحرب
الكثير من الافلام ولم ينتصر الا في
افلامهم فقط اما الواقع فهو يقول غير ذلك
نحن لا نتحدث عن حرب خاضتها امريكا في
معركه الاشباح نحن نتحدث عن حرب فيتنام
فيتنام نعم بات مان
مقبلات الحرب الاليمه هي احدى اهم الحروب
في القرن العشرين بان الحرب البارده نارت
راحاها بين الولايات المتحده وفيتنام حرب
استمرت لعشرين عاما للقضاء على الشيوعيه
وانقاذ الراسماليه ولكن دعونا نشرح لكم
باختصار الفرق بين الشيوعيه والراسماليه
في النظام الشيوعي تسيطر الدوله على
المصانع والشركات ولا يسمح بالملكيه
الخاصه وهي من تحدد اسعار الخدمات
والمنتجات اما في النظام الراسمالي فيسمح
للافراد بامتلاك المصانع والشركات مثل
ايلون ماسك وغيره ومن يحدد اسعار السلع هو
قانون العرض والطلب لنعد الى موضوعنا
الوثائق السريه اثبتت ان الملف الاسود
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه يقع في فيتنام
حيث ارتكب الامريكانو جرائم حرب ومجازر هي
الابشع في تاريخ الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لكن قبل ذلك كانت احدى اقوى
الدول في العالم تتلقى ابشع هزائمها على
يد الفيتناميين حين تم الاعلان عن هزيمه
قوات الاحتلال الفرنسي في معركه
وانسحابها من فيتنام عام
لتنقسم فيتنام بعدها لدولتين شماليه
وجنوبيه والقادم ادهى وامر عندها قرار
الفيتناميون بشمالهم وجنوبهم اجراء
انتخابات لمن يحكم البلاد وبينما كان فوز
الشيوعيين الشماليين حتميا بهذه
الانتخابات بسبب الدعم الشعبي الكبير الذي
حظوا به بالمناطق الريفيه
اتجه الزعيم الجنوبي نهض جنبي دعم من
الامريكيين لرفض النتائج فاندلعت حرب
فيتنام يا ساده وعينك مكشوف الا النور كما
يقولها المصريون شهدت بدايه هذه الحرب
دعما امريكيا كبيرا سرعان ما تحول ذلك
الدعم لتدخل عسكري مباشر عقب حادثه خليج
تونكينج والتي تعرضت فيه مدمرتان
امريكيتان للهجوم بزوارق وتربيدات
فيتناميه وكان الامريكان كانوا يبحثون عن
اي سبب للتدخل وهم قد وجدوا السبب يا
ليتنا وصفنا بالجبناء ولم ندخل هذه البلاد
ولم نعرف ابدا هذا ما كان يقوله لسان حال
الامريكان بعد نهايه الحرب
الارض المحروقه دون جدوى امريكا تتجبر
وتزيد في طغيانها ولم تترك اي وسيله
عسكريه للضغط على هنوي الا واستعملتها
فكثفت القصف على المدن واحرقت الغطاء
النباتي بطائره في اسلوب الارض المحروقه
الامريكانو يريدون اباده كل ما يمت
لاعدائهم الفيتناميين بصله بق
[موسيقى]
ولكن النتائج لا تتحدث الا عن الضحايا
المدنيين اما المقاتلون فكانوا اشد ذكاء
فهم لا يتجمعون ولا يظهرون في اراضي
مكشوفه ونحن نصل للعام
1968 حين اطلقت ثوار ما عرف بهجوم تيته
على مجموعه عمليات عسكريه امريكيه شديده
التحصين مستهدفين اكثر من 100 هدف حضري
وقد استطاعتبار ان يتغلغلوا في الجنوب حتى
بلغوا عاصمه الجنوب فتعرض الامريكيون
للهجوم ومع ان الثوار الفيتناميين فقدوا
حوالي 85 الف شخص في تلك الهجمات فان
التاثير النفسي للمعارك كان بالغ الاثر
على الولايات المتحده ليدخل الجنود
الامريكان في نوبات من الهلع من هذه
المقاومه التي ليس لديها جيش منظم اساسا
لانها نكلت بالامريكيين في حرب مدنيه داخل
المدن واوساط القرى الفيتناميون على ارضهم
وبين جماهيرهم مع دعم بالاسلحه من الاتحاد
السوفيتي روسيا حاليا والصين والامريكيون
بعودتهم واعتادهم الخارق لكن على ارض لم
يقاتلوا علي من قبل انها الارض التي طردت
الجيش الفرنسي قبل سنوات وبسبب خصوبه
الارض الفيتناميه وتنوع نباتاتها ادمن
الجيش الامريكي على تعاطي بعض النباتات
المخدرات للهروب من الواقع المؤلم حتى ان
الفيتناميين كسبوا بعض المعارك واخترقوا
العديد من القواعد الامريكيه بكل سهوله
ودون اي مقاومه امريكيه بسبب رفض الكثير
من الجنود الامريكان بهذه الحرب لانها لا
تحمل اي دافع وطني او مكاسب قوميه واما
الجنود الذين يعودون الى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
بامراض نفسيه وتشنجات عصبيه وفوبيا حتى من
اصوات المفرقعات الوضع في الداخل الامريكي
يزداد سوءا والشعب الامريكي يغلي رافضا
تلك الحرب التي عادت عليهم باسوء العواقب
الخسائر الامريكيه المرعبه نحن نتحدث عن
حرب تسببت في موت ملايين الاشخاص في
فيتنام ولكنها كشفت في النهايه عن ضعف
الامريكي وتاكد الجميع انه مجرد جيش
كرتوني وان ما نشاهده في الافلام لا يمت
للواقع بصله نعم فداك الصراع الاكبر في
العصر الحديث اسفر عن مقتل اكثر من 100
الف جندي امريكي وهذا هو من رقم مرعب
فجيوش بعض الدول باكملها لا تصلوا لهذا
الرقم وخسرت فيها امريكا اكثر من 100
مليار دولار وكما يقولها اليمني من طلب
الجن ركضوا اي ان الذي يستحضر الجن يقومون
بضربه اولا وهناك اعلن الرئيس الامريكي
انذاك جونسون وقف القصف الامريكي لشمال
فيتنام على 68 وفي العام التالي لم يكد
باتشر سن الرئيس الامريكي الجديد يصل الى
رئاسه البلاد حتى اعلن مغادره عشرات
الالاف من جنوده لفيتنام ومع ارتفاع خسائر
امريكا بشريا وماديا ازدادت قوه الدعوه
المطالبه بايقاف الحرب بعد ان نشرت وسائل
الاعلام الامريكيه الممارسات التي وصفت
بالبشعه وغير الانسانيه التي عمل بها
الجيش الامريكي المواطنين الفيتناميين ومع
انتعاش الامان بالوصول الى حل نهائي وفي
محاوله للضغط على الفيتناميين وكسب
انتصارات ميدانيه تقوي من موقفه امر
الرئيس نيكسون يوم 17 من ديسمبر عام 72
بقصف
[موسيقى]
نيرانها على المدينتين في قصر لم تعرف
الحرب الفيتناميه نظيرا وفقدت امريكا خمسه
عشره من هذه الطائرات كما فقدت ثلاثه 93
ضابطا من سلاح الطيران الامريكي وفي مطلع
عام
1973 تم الاعلان عن التوصل الى اتفاق وقف
اطلاق النار مع توقف جميع انواع العداء
وانسحاب القوات الامريكيه من جنوب فيتنام
خلال الشهرين التاليين للتوقيع واطلاق
سراح الاسرى من الطرفين خلال 15 يوما من
التوقيع لم ينتهي مارس عام 73 حتى غادر
اخر جندي امريكي فيتنام ولكن بفضيحه مذله
لاقوى جيش في العالم بعدما تعرضت واشنطن
لخسائر هائله في الارواح وخسائر ماديه
ضخمه وبعد انسحاب القوات
وانهزم حلفاء الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لصالح باتمام الشمالي المدعومه من قبل
الاتحاد السوفيتي في ذلك الحين وبالاضافه
الى مئه الف قتيل من الجنود الامريكان
خلفت الحرب اكثر من 153 الف جريحه ونحو
50087 اسيرا ونحن لا زلنا نتحدث عن
الخسائر الامريكيه فقط وصحيح بان
الفيتناميين خسروا خلال اعوام الحرب
الثمانيه ما يقارب مليونير قتيل وثلاثه
ملايين جريح معظمهم مدنيون من النساء
والاطفال وما يصل لثني عشر مليون لاجئ
فيفيتنام تعلمت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الدرس فمهما بلغت قوتها فلن
تقاتل بمفردها بعد حرب فيتنام لان الخساره
هي مصيرها ان قاتلت على انفراد لكن القتال
في تحالفات هي الطريقه الامريكيه منذ ذلك
الحين حتى يتحمل الحلفاء نصيبهم من
الخسائر فيا لها من خطه
[موسيقى]